en septembre on a moins de lits qu'en
janvier par les plans d'économies ont
continué dans les hôpitaux y compris
dans des lits de réanimation qu on vous
voyait que un lieu aussi symbolique le
chu de strasbourg a dû fermer 14 lits de
réanimation dans deux hôpitaux on voit
le décalage entre les besoins de la
population et les plans d'économies du
gouvernement sur sur les hôpitaux qui
perdure me suivait rang qui parlait des
700 mille tests alors que santé publique
que france dans ces derniers chiffes du
20 août et à 540 me teste par semaine
donc il ya aussi un problème de
fiabilité de la parole gouvernementale
qui est quand même assez inquiétante
ce qui nous inquiète c'est la tension
que l'on constate sur le matériel dont
on a besoin pour faire affaire les soins
c'est à dire que si on a assez de
masques chirurgicaux
on ment que toujours ans de masques ffp2
ya des tensions sur les gants médicaux
sur les sur blues
alors que on est trois mois après une
baisse de l'activité qu'ovide ce qui
veut dire que si on se retrouve face à
un nouveau pic que ce soit une deuxième
vague ou un rebond on va vite à être à
court de matériel de protection donc ça
on est particulièrement inquiet parce
que le gouvernement et est toujours en
retard n'est pas dans l'anticipation et
on risque de se retrouver avec des sacs
poubelles sur le dos comme il ya
quelques mois
[Musique]